this topic that we're starting is called
applications of differentiation the most
recent thing we've been doing is like
integration and graphing closely related
but not the same thing so that's why if
we're gonna be able to apply
differentiation we've got to be able to
you know differentiate so we're trying
to get our brains back in the space do
not feel bad this is the way that we
experience all new skills when you're
like okay
my brain just hasn't been in this mode
for a while okay I deliberately gave you
a whole bunch of different ones that
sort of tests like all different bits of
differentiation so that was kind of hard
you know an exercise usually just says
here's five of the same kind of thing
you get into rhythm and I've not let you
getting to rhythm so don't feel bad if
you struggled a little bit several of
you taught 1 y equals 3 X to the 5 minus
4 X are we happy with that derivative
what do you think yes I kind of started
off with this one cuz I thought
polynomials are where we begin and after
we stopped confusing with whether we
need a plus C or not which is an easy
mistake to make and we remember that we
bring the index down it multiplies
reduce that index by 1 and then for this
guy you do the same thing this ends up
being minus 4 X to the 0 but of course
you don't need to write X to the 0 right
since it's just 1 so this looks great
I've probably would have written dy on
DX is a minor thing Y - is fine as you
know but why might we try and avoid
writing that if we can have a think
about the way that we've actually
written their answer what what does that
- look like to you it could be a 1 right
like in fact that's exactly how I write
my ones when they're in the X index so
if I don't get given - notation I don't
use it because it's so easy to mistake
looks fine FX here you do you have to
use F - for this and what rule did I'm
Eddie you did this one right I'm what
rule did Eddie use when he was doing
this question string query I'm very good
because this is something divided by
something we try to avoid the question
rule because it's messy but when you get
handed a question just just use it okay
some of you tripped yourselves up
because you kind of skipped this very
very tiny step of making sure you know
which part of the function is which
right which bits you which would be very
easy to confuse why does it matter by
the way with the product rule doesn't
matter I didn't give you a product why
does it matter with the Christian world
which one's you and which ones me yeah
well
yeah exactly
in this case division right it's an
operation where the order matters and
also when you come over to the quotient
rule can I just get a quick show of
hands how many people actually wrote the
question rule V u - - u v - before
actually doing the stuff heads up yeah
cool all right I think he hears that I
mean I've been doing this for like 20
years right I still write that rule
because I don't like keeping this in my
head and it's so easy to get this next
step wrong as several of you did if you
skip that okay so watch out for it does
that look okay is that that's our this
is actually you've written the order
slightly differently Eddy but I think
you've come out with the right answer
that looks like you've actually no you
skipped a line haven't you there's a
line you haven't written here but that's
that's okay and this is what happens
when you've expanded everything that you
get from your V you - - UV - one final
step - here what's he done by the way
from the first thing is written - the
last thing is written what's the
difference we have a name for this
process that's within their
factorization right factorization is not
necessary unless I tell you but as
you'll see as we go further into this
topic this topic especially
factorization is something you should
get used to doing as like your final
step because it ends up being very
useful for what we do next all right
Michonne had a go at this one now we
haven't given this a name so I guess if
fish on saying the derivative is f -
let's call this thing f
please note by the way because I saw a
few of you I deliberately did this
because I mean like that I'm a bunch of
you just wrote your answer is this don't
not care and tell me why that's
problematic there's no y there's no
thing that's being differentiated right
this is a this is what we call an
operator do you remember that we call
this the differential operator so if
you're a D on DX equals on your book
like look at your page right now please
change that either put something there
or label it in some other way good
morning okay are we happy with this
derivative that he's come up with yeah
I'm there's two pieces to it right
where's that three come from well it
just sort of appear from different right
it came from here right it came from the
inside to remove to remember this we're
using the chain rule even then we
haven't said it and then why did this
change cuz then we had to do a
last-minute change right
why does sign change it to cause the
textbook does say this there's a reason
why the textbook says I can't we've
we've differentiated sign at the outside
function sign turns into cause okay last
one here I just gonna leave that one if
these are ones you're struggling to call
back into your memory this is precisely
why we give you the reference sheet and
if you don't have one or you've lost the
one that we printed out